HIEs can vary substantially in scope.
An HIE can serve a single health
enterprise that may consist of
more than one hospital,
many physician practices, and
other entities such as nursing homes or
rehabilitation facilities.
These entities may have electronic
medical records from different vendors
so interoperability can be an issue
even within a single health system or
enterprise.
Some health systems extend their HIE to
practices that refer patients to them
in an effort to make that easier and
thereby attract more referrals.
This is often called a Service Area HIE.
In an effort to better position
the health system to contract under
arrangements like an ACO,
it is increasingly common for
them to actually acquire these
outlying medical practices,
in which case they would definitely want
them included in the enterprise HIE.